before we go newborn twins are making  history in Germany let me explain a  panda at the Berlin Zoo gave birth to  two cubs on Saturday the tiny pink twins  are the first giant pandas born in  Germany right now they're only about the  size of a person's hand one of the Cubs  squealed and wiggled while new mom  ming-ming picked it up with her mouth  she then cradled her new baby and gave  it a bath with her tongue as panda moms  do normally when a panda gives birth to  twins she only raises one of the Cubs so  ming-ming will get help from zoo staff  to raise both of them the zoo says mom  and babies are healthy and doing well so  small nothing giant about those pandas  yet yet watch out but give it time